what's up everyone it's Warren and
earlier this week we got the first
official teaser trailer for Black Widow
in the first official teaser trailer for
phase four a great way to kick off the
week but this weekend tomorrow actually
we have the Comic Con experience at
South Paulo Brazil where Marvel gets 45
minutes to talk about whatever they want
and not to mention it is Marvel Studios
President Kevin Feige who is going to be
leading the panel himself so what
exactly does Marvel have planned this
weekend and what can we expect to hear
well there are three things that could
possibly happen that if they do happen
will be super exciting so be sure to
subscribe with notifications turned on
so you don't miss anything that happens
tomorrow at cc XP so one thing that
could possibly happen and is really most
likely to happen is that we could be
getting some footage of phase 4 now even
though we just got the teaser trailer
for Black Widow this will most likely be
of black widow or they could tease us
with some footage of the Eternals
filming for the Eternals has been going
on for some time now so it is possible
that Marvel could be showing us some
footage from the movie the Eternals is
the one movie that Marvel is going to
try to get everybody really really
excited for because people really don't
know what to expect from the movie so
it's possible just to raise some hype
that they could show us some footage at
CC XP another thing that is possible
that has people very very excited is
that Ryan Reynolds is going to be in
attendance at CC XP and they could do an
official Deadpool 3 announcement now it
may not be called Deadpool 3 it could
just be Deadpool it could just be a
reboot the way the Deadpool movies work
make it pretty easy to do a reboot if
they get rid of everybody but Ryan
Reynolds because of course Ryan Reynolds
is stain and going to be playing
Deadpool still then it'll be pretty easy
for Deadpool to make a joke break the
fourth wall talk about how nobody's
there before and technically he's in a
different universe now so it's very
possible that we could be getting an
official Deadpool in the MCU
announcement because Marvel has done
this before in 2016 at San Diego Comic
Con brie Larson was there but she was
there to promote Kong Skull Island
however that did not stop Marvel from
bringing her on to their stage during
their panel and officially announcing
her as Captain Marvel and we know that
Ryan Reynolds has recently met with
Marvel Studios so it seems like we could
be getting a Deadpool announcement this
weekend
and another thing that we could be
getting and are most likely going to get
which is the biggest of them all is a
phase 5 reveal now this could be a
partial reveal where they just talked
about a few new movies that are going to
be coming or they could reveal the whole
entire slate again Marvel has 45 minutes
which is actually twice the amount of
time that it took them to reveal phase 3
so plenty of time to reveal phase 4 and
Kevin Feige has already stated after San
Diego Comic Cons reveal of phase 4 that
they already have phase 5 done they
actually had plans to reveal it at San
Diego comic-con but they didn't want to
rush phase 4 but they've already
confirmed some movies like black panther
2 already has a release date blade is
confirmed to be coming as well not to
mention guardians of the galaxy vol 3
and also Ant Man 3 as well so we already
know quite a lot about phase 5 actually
so this weekend Marvel may just reveal
the entire slate to us since most of it
is already known however Marvel does
like to throw some curveballs in there
and there's most likely one movie that's
going to be thrown into phase 5 that
none of us are expecting to see and that
will most likely be a Fantastic Four
movie Kevin Feige did tease this at San
Diego comic-con although none of us are
expecting it as soon as phase 5
we know that Marvel is going to take
their time with the Fox characters that
they recently got but perhaps since the
Fantastic Four are only four or five
characters if you include a villain and
not a whole entire team like the x-men
perhaps we could get them in Phase five
and perhaps that could be revealed
tomorrow so a lot of exciting things are
coming from tomorrow's Marvel panel at
CC XP big reveals no matter what it'll
be really exciting to see what they are
out of everything that could be revealed
what would you like to see Deadpool the
Fantastic Four a whole entire phase 5
slate reveal let me know what you want
to see in the comments down below I'm
still giving away an Xbox we're at ps4
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
but when notifications turned on liked
this video and leave a comment down
below also my G fuel code is now 30% off
so be sure to use code cosmic when you
check out at G feel calm as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof woof
you